this whole thing about abundance and
attracting to yourself what it is that
you want and how to use mantras and
spirituality to make sure you have what
you want true spirituality is about not
wanting is about being filled with joy
from inside and then sharing that
outside it's not about attracting to
yourself what you want people ask me is
there a law of attraction yes and you
better be scared of it because if it's
true that you attract what your mind is
thinking you better take a look at what
your mind is thinking what about your
mind all day when it's complaining and
it's yelling at people and it doesn't
like stuff but if you're attracting that
way so you eventually catch on that it
is not about getting what you want it is
about learning to find out that what you
really want is to stay open and not have
conditions on that openness and then it
comes down to how do you do that are
people capable of doing that or is that
just reserved for you know some special
beings Buddha and Christ that have
walked the face of the Earth everybody
is capable of that if I tell you to pick
up five thousand pounds you may not be
able to do that so I've told you to do
something that you have never done and
you're not doing it so you may not be
able to do it but if you're actually
already doing something and I tell you
not to do it you're always capable of
that because you're the one who's doing
it need motivations watch a top ten with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos
but first business I struggle to believe
in myself I quit on my business partner
and the thing that saved me was watching
the successful stories of entrepreneurs
they gave me the inspiration to keep
going as well as the strategies of what
to do and quite honestly I still need
their stories and motivation today as
well so today let's learn from one of
the best Michael Singer and my take on
his top 10 rules of success
enjoy
inside you are the one who's closing
your heart you close it you are the one
who's closing your mind you do that
they're your thoughts it's your feelings
there's nobody else's so you are in
there doing these things so if I tell
you the way to stay open is to not close
I don't teach how to stay open that's
more like finding out how to get what
you want I'm interested in you learning
to not close but a difference if I say
to you I want you to open your heart
right now you wouldn't even know how to
start
but if I say to you somebody says and
you don't like don't close you know
where to start right because it's
happening inside of you and you see the
tendency to do it all I'm asking you to
do is don't do that I'm telling you that
will take you the whole way don't worry
about opening worry about not closing
there are going to be events that unfold
in your life that naturally open you a
beautiful sunset a bird singing
sometimes you get what your mind wants
all right you open great nothing wrong
with that don't close
how come it only last a minute I'm going
to see a beautiful sunset you feel like
oh my God I looked in the face of God
then you go right back into your mind
with all your problems why
why don't you learn to not close why
don't you get some openness start to
work with yourself to not close and this
is how to get what you really want the
teeth the Deep spiritual teachings are
really teaching you how to get what you
want because what you want is to feel
love and joy and happiness all the time
and so if you can get that from within
you then can share it rule number two is
discover your real self the mind is very
strong
and one of the things the Mind does is
develop methodologies or ways of
thinking that let it interact with life
and not get hurt and be more comfortable
and it's the ego when we develop a
self-concept and we change it through
our lives but in general there's a
self-concept sitting under there saying
I was the one that did this and I was
the one that went to the school and I'm
the one that went there and the one that
my father left or stayed or whatever the
hell it is excuse me and basically uh
all of this unfolds and you end up
developing patterns of thinking based
upon the experiences you've had all
right and what I'm saying at least
certainly in my experience is that's not
what makes you wake up that's what keeps
you from waking up
all right the fact that you're
identifying with these past experiences
and saying that's who I am well it's not
who you are you are watching your ego
you see it get upset you see it fix
things you see it have Concepts and
Views and Etc et cetera and even you're
obviously very intelligent you can use
your intellect to support the ego to
support that and and so on right and I'm
sure yes you're a very special person
very intelligent person and therefore
that becomes part of your self-concept
okay and then you say a religious person
part of your self-concept all of these
things are ways you think of yourself
and there's nothing at all wrong with
that it's wonderful you've been
successful you're happy you're doing
well all right I'm not happy I'm not
doing well I just said that
and also like weeping openly at this
moment okay but listen to me right that
identification with your personal self
which is just your mind's thoughts are
what keep you from waking up rule number
three is recognize your needs instead of
asking why am I not okay why I'm not
okay you're asking what do I need to be
okay that's the major difference of
whether you're growing inwardly or
you're attached to struggling externally
is you think I can only be okay if I get
the things that I got before
or similar you extrapolate right things
that made me had a relationship and
eighth grade and it was so beautiful and
she was redheaded okay my wife no that's
not true all right
he was redheaded and she left you know
so her parents move right and it was
never a bad experience in that
relationship it was just the most
perfect relationship you've ever had
right you understand now if I'm grown up
and I I go on a date and shoot a red hat
she redheaded I have a pretense
propensity toward being open you just
asked a question why do we think we need
these things all right because we're not
okay inside and we've had experiences
either you read a book it'll tell you
you need that to be okay you watch a
movie meet somebody you can have a
thought
if I had a Tesla
okay it used to be a Ferrari that's a
Tesla all right I I man everyone would
be proud of me and I feel like I'm
helping the ecology and so all of a
sudden I'm not okay I'm going to go to
Tesla and if I get a Tesla oh my God for
a while how am I doing wonderful so
that's how you develop your preferences
is through programming you get
programmed by your past experiences rule
number four is find out what you really
want what do you really want
we talk about wisdom people talk about
attracting to themselves The Laws of
Attraction and all those sorts of things
but the question really is from a
spiritual point of view what do you
really want and religions about what
you're supposed to want and we know how
that works
spirituality is not about that
spirituality is about looking deeply
Within
and seeking truth Clarity that's what
it's about so this discussion is has
nothing to do with my feeling what you
should want or you even feeling guilty
or
weird about what you do want the
question is what do you really want
and the way to do that and I'm going to
be very bad in doing this is to say
here's a piece of paper not really but
figuratively and I want you to write
down what you want just take a little
time don't do it take a little time and
write down what you want and if you're
like most human beings probably first on
the list is a good relationship
something that makes me feel important
needed wanted loved secure all that kind
of stuff and so whether you're in a
relationship I'd like it to get better
or someone so should behave in different
ways should understand me better
Etc or if you're not in a relationship
how to find my quote soul mate somebody
who just fits perfectly with me and just
fulfills the meaning of my life and uh
if we're really honest we write down a
nice house and a Ferrari or at least
some sort of a car and perhaps children
and or perhaps a little time without the
children and we make our list nobody's
judging just be honest you put that down
the purpose of this discussion is no
matter what you put on that list unless
you're very highly evolved
my experience is it's not really what
you want it's not that it's wrong it's
just not really what you want and the
way I prove that is as follows let's say
you put down I want a relationship I
want to meet somebody I want to have
that special relationship
and then I would ask you what if you
walked outside after this conversation
and all of a sudden there was this bush
in front of you and it started burning
like it did to Moses
and talking to you and its opening
sentence was I am the Lord your God
and I would like to discuss some things
with you
and said enough things that it knew
about you to where you were pretty
freaked out that you're actually talking
to an omniscient omniscient omnipotent
being or at least bush
and
the question that gets asked of you is
what would you like what do you want I
can grant whatever you want and having
gone through this exercise with me you
feel God thank God Mickey I'm prepared
this is neat I thought about it and you
say I want a relationship I want to meet
somebody I want to have that that thing
I've looked for my whole life or I want
a house or I want the perfect job I want
a job that makes me you know that
fulfills what I'm looking for
and what this push what God tells you at
that point is I can give you that I have
the power to give you that but there's a
caveat which you probably want to hear
before I give it to you which is
I can give you that perfect person
they will be loyal to you they will stay
with you your entire life
but the caveat is
that you will be completely unfulfilled
you will feel sad every time you come
into the presence
you will not feel any love you will not
feel any joy happiness meaning but
they'll be there and they will dote all
over you and they will just be the most
perfect partner
that they could possibly be
or give you the job that you thought
would be the most amazing thing but it's
Hollow for you you go there and you
thought it would turn you on but it
doesn't
and you just Lowe's going to work and
you're just not excited about it
so therein lies there what do you really
want
because what you're going to find is if
you were given the opportunity to have a
relationship with that person I just
described or have the job I just
subscribed but it didn't do squat for
you and it left you hollow inside you
would say I don't want it in fact if
it's going to make me miserable inside I
really don't want to keep it away from
me
and so to move quickly because we don't
have a little time here then I say to
you lied to me when you said it was what
you really wanted
because it isn't true you wanted a
relationship it isn't true you aren't
children it isn't true you wanted money
it isn't true you wanted to travel
around the world it isn't true that you
want it Etc et cetera what's true is you
wanted to feel good inside
you want to feel love you want to feel
Joy you want to feel inspiration
excitement meaning those are inner
things there are outer things
you listed the things you listed
because you thought they would give you
what you really want
and so wisdom yoga spirituality
is about going deeper Buddhists talk
about working at the root so the truth
of the matter is the only thing you need
to write needed to write on a piece of
paper when I asked you what do you
really want
is a sense of total well-being
I want to feel love I want to feel Joy I
want to feel inspiration I want to feel
meaning and depth also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five is overcome anxiety
what you want to do is say what's behind
the anxiety so when when people talk I
don't help people make decisions but we
talk about decision making is the first
thing that matters is what's your motive
now what should you do if how can you
figure out what to do if you don't even
know your motive right and my you became
the spiritual teacher with every word
you said about this which is start from
the point of view do I want to get a
house or not
oh okay yes I like that house all right
can I afford a house don't worry about
what house what's your motive it's very
simple you know it's just I'm just want
to express myself and have a house and
and that's that and then stop there
don't say it has to be a certain way
when it's all said and done if you're
afraid of making the wrong decision who
defined it is wrong you well then don't
that's not what I was saying right if
you don't Define it as wrong I was a
builder okay you know I I before my
personal experience for the program
company I did go with love my company I
built this house for this beautiful lady
all right who happened to be the manager
of the local bank and her name was Penny
dollar
I swear to God her name was Penny dollar
right this is a long time ago back in
the 80s and basically she once came to
me and sat there and said I'm so scared
I said look I I'm gonna build a
beautiful house for you we've got it
everything's fine so I step in nights I
can't sleep what are you worried about
isn't it turning out nice I'm afraid
listen to this I'm afraid that I will
build the house and then I'll go to plug
in a lamp and the cord won't reach the
outlet
wow wow
thank you I said wow that's why they
make a stingy course
I was gonna say that's why they make
therapists but yes rule number six is
stop negativity when I was you know 22
23 years old
I realized that that voice was running
my life
and that's what you're saying if it
wasn't comfortable I left
if it you know whatever it was it was
determining what I said it was
determined how I acted it was
determining everything about my life and
yet I didn't know a thing about that
voice why was it saying what it was
saying why why is it like one person and
not another because when you like
somebody your voice says I like her so
from right and if all of a sudden it
said no I don't think so I don't think
then you don't it's like telling you and
your emotions go along with it and it's
this whole psychological system that's
going on inside so I made the decision
not and I'm not saying people should
right but it's nice to share that I
wasn't going to live my life without
understanding what was going on because
it didn't make sense okay and it already
caused a lot of trouble in my life just
like it does everybody else's all right
it's like oh your relations is so hard
and everything else and changing jobs it
just decides I don't like my boss I
don't like the boss anymore it's telling
you that why didn't it just say I like
the boss
like no one actually pays attention to
how much control it has over your life
or why it's saying what it's saying so
what I did was to say I'm going to take
a little sabbatical hiatus
about a year or so I meant to put aside
and devote my life to watching that
voice and figure out why it says what it
says what is my relationship to it and I
in essence dropped out I don't like
teaching that now because people
shouldn't drop out I mean not they
shouldn't but they don't need to and I'm
not teaching them to right but I did I
was it was a I think you know I was in a
doctoral program for economics the
university and last year ready to get my
doctorate and I stepped aside and went
into Solitude relative Solitude and I
watched very very carefully and what I
saw made me more uncomfortable than what
you were talking about all right like
watching it when it was in his glory
because you know you pull yourself aside
it's going to say a lot of stuff made me
realize I don't listen to that thing
that thing's crazy it just changed his
mind all the time it says this it says
that like the reason people drink and do
drugs is because that thing's driving
them crazy do you understand that are
you trying to get away from that in
inner mess that's going on inside so
basically over the course of many years
I started an experiment which was what
would happen if I didn't listen to that
what does that mean it tells you what to
do and so on well what if I listen to
Life instead and that's very subtle well
what if the events unfolding in front of
me were more important than whether I
like them or not
and I was willing to listen if I'm
meeting this person perhaps it has some
meaning the fact that I'm not
comfortable with them maybe has no
meaning right and I started practicing
letting go of myself instead of letting
go of what it told me to and and
sometimes it told me to do something
sometimes I wouldn't do it what I got
was as follows
just because it told me to do it is not
going to be the reason I do it just
because it told me not to do it isn't or
that it doesn't like it it's not going
to be the reason I don't do it that
doesn't mean that I'm doing or not doing
I will let life the unfolding of Life
the circumstances that unfold in front
of me talk to me instead of that thing
talking to me so that that's the basics
of what I call surrender you're not
surrendering to life you're not
surrendering to people you're not saying
yes to everything you're just basically
saying my head doesn't know what it's
talking about it's just a bunch of noise
he's making a little allergies it's just
a bunch of noise and I'm better off not
listening to that personal noise doesn't
mean intellectually if I'm solving a
math problem or I'm trying to decide you
know create air conditioning or building
I I built for a while reading plans and
so on the mind's wonderful for that I'm
talking about the personal mind I like
this I don't like that I believe in this
I don't believe in that I want this to
happen oh my God I hope it doesn't rain
tomorrow because I'll die if it rains
that kind of junk just the personal
noise that instead of honoring and
respecting life is judging it and trying
to tell me how to make life be my way
instead of my respecting that life took
13.8 billion years to get here that's
that's a big stick I have right that
every moment in front of me took every
single thing to happen exactly like it
did for 13.8 billion years for that
thing to be in front of me do you
understand that because if you're if
you're a great great great grandmother
didn't meet your great great great
grandfather you're not here
okay rule number seven is B The Observer
you're trying to make your Neurosis or
your anxiety relax no anxiety doesn't
know how to relax anxiety is anxious
you're saying that it's just nature
right it's all jumpy and stuff like that
right but you who's noticing it you has
the hands in there you can relax you can
sit there and say okay fine just relax
and lean away from the noise just go to
that place okay that's all it's like a
Zone
athletes talk about being in the zone
right there's a Zone inside if you relax
behind that noise there's a piece back
there there's a there's a quiet doesn't
be a big spiritual experience but it's a
heck of a lot nicer than hanging out
with anxiety yeah it's the Observer
that's what it feels like you're the
Observer and you relax and if you do
that over time not immediately but over
time you will find that that which was
making you anxious the Neurosis
downstairs oh my God my boss is going
man I told him I'd be there I'm going to
be late you could be just as late anyway
sorry it's not going to change the thing
you look at that and you realize I'm
okay I'm okay it doesn't do any good to
show up neurotic okay so you let go and
as you let go you'll notice amazing
thing that energy that was all weird
because you didn't touch it it changed
it was able to come up all right or you
start using affirmation right you sit
there and say oh come on this is
probably a an older person like my
grandmother my grandmother I do yes yes
that's right they get to drive and I
should not be talking at them or
bothering them or even sending them bad
vibes maybe they should not be driving
any faster well well and the point is
it's a latter part of their life and at
least they get to go some places or
something and it means a lot more to
them than this Neurosis means to me and
you feel like you're giving something
instead of demanding and taking you can
change yourself it's not about
suppressing it's not about denying it's
about raising you raise yourself pausing
almost feels like it generates
compassion a little bit what you'll find
out is you back there are the most
beautiful thing in the whole universe
you are filled with love you're filled
with compassion you're filled with
inspiration you're filled with Michael
shock the energy just Spirit energy
equal whatever you want filled with it
all the time but you're busy looking
down at this garbage and so you learn to
raise yourself the other example that I
like to use because I'm very much into
being Broad and seeing the whole
universe instead of just your little
tiny world right is let's say it's hot
out nowadays you have global warming
we're hot okay it's very hot out you're
standing there and you have to go from
one place to another and you're actually
outside with no air conditioning isn't
that terrible and as you're walking
you're complaining oh my God it's so
freaking hot and I'm sweating I don't
want to sweat I don't like this sort of
thing and I always have to be so hot
what's wrong with these people blah blah
okay well that doesn't help anything it
doesn't make it cooler it doesn't do a
single thing it's the same thing like
the car but what if you sat there I know
I trained Mickey this I trained Michael
this way all right as I sit there and I
look and I say how did it get hot be
quiet how did it get hot what do you
mean why is it hot
well because there's a son out there you
mean there's a star 93 billion miles
away and you're it's hot it's so hot
that you feel it's heat here I'm in
Gainesville Florida Miami is about 300
miles away I asked them how big would a
fire have to be in Miami for you to
steal it in Gainesville if the whole
town caught fire you would not even know
what happened that thing's 93 million
you're a dollar ago it's 93 million
miles away and you can feel the star
shine okay you can feel is that means
yeah I could feel a star the stars are
neat things right and you start working
with yourself that way and it works you
raise yourself
number eight is recondition your mind we
call a mindset it's a conditioning of
the mind that makes it so that things
turn you on and turn you off and that's
where you get your list of what you want
and what you don't want it is not true
that you want those things
what you want is something that will
open you so that you can feel the joy
that is natural when you're open and you
don't want the things that close you so
that you get blocked off from any joy
and you get this sense of depression so
you have a choice even right at that
point we haven't even gone deep yet you
have a choice do you want to spend your
life
deciding what you want and what you
don't want and then chasing it outside
or do you want to sit there and work
inside to realize all I really want is
the joy and the love and if I stay open
I can have those I don't need outside
conditions to keep me open so I make it
I make a very important point because in
spirituality it gets mixed up
spirituality is not about renunciation
there's no renunciation pronunciation
says I've decided what it is that will
make me happy and I'm not going to do it
well that sounds rather absurd all right
spirituality says it was stupid of me to
decide what will make me happy instead
of being happy with life instead of
being grateful and turned on by all of
the amazing things that are happening in
front of me and all the past experiences
I got to have why don't I just enjoy all
that and then come into life filled with
love filled with joy and give the hold
of my being to the moments that
unfolding in front of me that's of
spirituality says so it's not about
renunciation it's not about things are
wrong and things are right
it's about understanding that you did
this you did this with your mind you set
up conditions in which your mind would
open and then your heart opens and
conditions in which your mind will close
and your heart closes so spirituality is
very positive you'll say spirituality is
not logical and rational it is so it's
saying to you why are you doing that if
you want to have a beautiful life spin
around a planet in the middle of
nowheres why don't you just open it's
your heart it's your mind it doesn't
need conditions to open it's just you
don't know how to do it as you become
used to programs uh habitual that you
had a past experience as by the way this
is where it comes from how did you
decide how did your mind decide what it
is you want and what you don't want you
did not make those decisions they were
programmed into you by your past
experiences all of them so you had a
past experience where something was nice
with a certain person they looked a
certain way they had a certain name they
drove a certain kind of car or whatever
it is and you really was really was high
for you it was beautiful years and years
ago now one of those things shows up you
meet somebody with that name as shallow
as that sounds don't kid yourself you
meet someone with the name of your ex
you close down even though it's not the
same person you meet someone with the
name of who you had your first date with
in high school that it was a wonderful
relationship and you open up and
likewise when you see a car they had a
nice experience in it turned you on so
you are programmed by your past
experiences such that if they were good
experiences they tend to open you when
something reminds you of them when they
were negative experience they tend to
close you and that is where you get your
list of what you want that's why all of
our lists are different everyone's
listening is totally different someone
tells you this is the same as yours
they're manipulating you because
everyone has had different experiences
and based upon those experiences it left
these Impressions on your mind and you
came up with this list of what I want so
when you make the list of what you want
what you don't want you're really making
a list of your past
yes how you came up with those things
even colors that you like anything
there are Impressions Skinner the
psychologist said man is the sum of his
learned experiences it's not true it's
true that your mind and your heart are
the your personal heart are the some of
your learned experiences but you are in
there noticing this so I make a big
distinction with BF right that you are
in there and you are noticing that your
mind is a some of your learned
experiences and it is that's what
psychology meets spirituality psychology
is right all of the psyche your thoughts
your patterns your likes your dislikes
your problems and neuroses Etc are the
some of your learned experiences but you
are in there you're the Consciousness
the awareness of being who notices that
what I'm saying is true
so basically you come to the point where
you have to decide do I want to continue
letting my past leave Impressions on my
mind and my heart such that only certain
things will open and close me and then I
will spend my life chasing after
manipulating controlling conniving
whatever you want
the world around me so that sometimes it
unfolds the way I want or do you want to
sit there and understand that you're the
one who's making these decisions it's
your mind who setting up the conditions
why don't you just not do that rule
number nine is think positively you can
start with positive thinking that's one
level that at least you should be doing
that right you sit there and say we'll
make it through this and even if I don't
whatever it is I will be a better person
because of this if you're in into God
running everything if that's your state
God knows what he's doing there are so
many different things that you can do
with positive thinking to create a nicer
environment inside in my opinion you
have an obligation to do that both for
yourself for the health of your body for
people around you you just lift yourself
up Vegeta says one should raise the
selfless self not trample down the self
this is a time to be doing that work so
you can't say I can't do that you can
make your mind say things you're going
to use say every time there's a negative
thought replace it with a positive one
it's a good time to practice that so
it's it's woeing for itself oh my God
this is terrible I'll be fine this is
okay God knows what he's doing or no
there's just reality it's just reality
he accepted either way and then the next
level is you sit there and if you do
Mantra and mantras have to be an Eastern
you know Sanskrit Mantra but just gets
something going behind that you're
hanging on to it a deeper part of your
mind I'll be okay this is okay I'll use
it whatever it is right then what will
happen is when the lower cell starts
these situations happen you just settle
back into it so you have a choice which
mind you want to listen to the lower
mind which we know what it's like or
you've built something beautiful inside
and then ultimately the highest state is
you relax every single time something
hits your stuff you relax you relax
relax and let go relaxing itself is
Letting Go people sometimes I say well I
relax I I let go the very fact that you
chose to relax relax your shoulders
lectures tummy Etc and and just relax
inside you that is Letting Go you're not
getting all involved in what's going on
so that's the highest state is you just
keep letting go and the worse it is the
better is keep letting go you just to
commit yourself I'm going to use this
right then you of course put aside some
time in the morning and evening to
remind yourself that this is what I'm
doing and Rule Number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
work on yourself all you can be
responsible for is yourself your
starting position is right you have to
evolve with the different situations
that are presented to you and my
experiences if you do that
the rest will happen the people around
you will be raised naturally understand
that like if you bring anger into a
situation imagine a household or is
always fighting if all of a sudden
somebody's not and somebody's bringing
understanding and love that's all they
have to do it will change things
right but you you can't sit there and
say I won't change it until everybody
else does
that doesn't work
right so that you're asking you like
there's no surprise you I said big
things all right it's like can it be
better of course it could be better but
it requires that everybody work on
themselves
because well they're not working on
themselves they're working on everybody
else they're just trying to manipulate
I was CEO of a public corporation went
through all kinds of stuff
I see no difference between
being in the temple Universe whatever it
is and I found it kind of people started
coming out there so it happened that's
how my whole life is right I never
decided to do anything I just followed
the energy like I was saying I'm there
doing Services you know meditating
whoever it is and different events
unfold the one particular one that I
tell in the surrender experiment is
a
serif came out to the land and I was
barefoot a hippie you know walking
around my land and he walked up to the
sample building that we built which I
was a little concerned you know has
Krishna and and Jewish things it has all
the different religions represented and
he's all dressed up in his officer
uniform and pulls his big car up there
and I'm walking around barefoot no shirt
on and he says uh you in charge here
uh and okay yeah I guess I am you know
he says
did you build this building
I said yes he said would you build an
addition on my house
I swear to God that's exactly what
happened all right and because I was
surrendering to life
nothing inside of me wanted to build a
closing the garage of this Sheriff all
right I'm not even a builder I built a
couple of buildings on my own land you
know rough sawn Timber Etc and I said
yes and that founded my first company
built with love and I ended up building
a custom houses and this and that and
then I got into computers and the next
thing I knew people were asking me write
computer programs and I just talked I
didn't know it was a course in my life I
just started writing as I found it
interesting like you find stuff
interesting and bought a Terrace 80
model one when Radio Shack first came
out with a little tiny computers all
right and wrote an accounting program to
run built with love and then people
wanted to buy the program
that's literally how this company
started and so I said okay I guess all
right let's start surrendering and then
I got to write this and write that and
do this and eventually somebody asked me
to write a medical billing system and I
had I didn't even go to the doctor in
those days and I'd never seen an
insurance form in my life all right and
I took it and I did it I did it and it
became this major company you know with
2300 employees and public and the whole
ball game and so I just had to do it I
just did it well while I was doing it I
didn't change I didn't say now this is
what I'm doing now this is a wonderful
opportunity to let go of me like you can
bet you know for sure you can bet that
being in that environment I mean
literally I'm on earning calls with Wall
Street like give me a break all right I
can't relate to any of it but I'm doing
my best I'm serving and working hard
doing everything as an act of letting go
of myself and serving the universe
course I never wasn't about business it
wasn't about this the other thing but
you do that you try as hard as you can
and just try to serve everybody and you
can do pretty well
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Bruce Lipton
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there Consciousness is
creating your reality if you put a
picture of fear into your reality then
your biology Behavior will manifest
things to be afraid of because this is a
short statement but to me it's the most
powerful